hello and welcome to tutorial concerning
pythons built-in counter function the
purpose of the counter function is to
well count I'm going to count the number
of iterations of every type of thing in
a list and then it creates a dictionary
of sorts of results in order from
greatest to least which contains a key
which is going to be the unique item and
then the value is going to be how many
instances of that item were found in a
list so think of this as a way to tally
occurrences of items in the list then
from there you can do all sorts of
things so you might just care about you
know how many instances of something
occurred in a list but you can also do
things like finding you know like X like
you can find the top three most popular
ones or the top five most common
occurring ones you can also add or
subtract from other counter lists so
let's say you have two lists of a bunch
of names and you want to figure out
which names are the most common you can
do that and then also you can find out
maybe how many more Kellie's are in one
list than the other list by doing a
subtraction function so you need to all
kinds of stuff like that so anyway let's
go ahead and take a look at this module
so the first thing that you're going to
need to do is import the counter so from
collections import counter and that's
going to be with a capital C from there
we need to make an example list so I'm
just going to say example list and then
that's going to equal just some numbers
you don't have to copy the same numbers
I do I'm just putting in literally
random numbers well not totally random
but just whatever anyway now to show you
the most basic use of counter we can do
something like this account's equals
capital c again don't forget that
counter and then in the parameters here
you put whatever you want to count
what's the list that you want to count
or in our case it's example list so now
what we can do is we can print counts
and let's go ahead and run that
and look at what our output is and make
this a little bit smaller here so this
is our output so as you can see the most
occurring item in our list was a 2 right
and so this is the key right if you're
not familiar with the dictionary so 2 is
the key and then 8 is how many
occurrences or instances of two we had
in that list and then the next most
common was a 1 with 3 and then as you
can see we have a next most common and
that's a 4 with 3 so what who decides on
whether it's 1 or 4 it's just completely
arbitrary I I'm not sure what makes them
choose maybe 1 over 3 maybe it's like
the which one appears first possibly
right so 1 appeared in the list before a
4 so it's probably something like that
that decides which one comes first
but anyway from there's what it probably
is doing is as it sees the number adds 1
and then is constantly ordering them and
so that's probably why number 1 appeared
first but not positive on that so let's
close that on let's see what some of the
other things that we can do so what not
only can we do this but it's a lot like
a dictionary so we can get how many of a
variable so let's say we wanted to do we
want to know how many instances of 3
there are in this list so you could say
like a systems specific equals a counts
3 and then we can print specific and I'm
just going to comment out this other
print that we did so we can run this and
as you see the output that we get is
just 1 there was only one occurrence of
a 3 but then we can put in I think 2 is
our most popular one so we could run
that and we have 8 occurrences so that's
how you can return on exactly how many
of us specifically write we're asking
how many twos were in them so I'm going
to comment this out and show you guys
some more stuff now what happens if you
ask
maybe the specific of something that
doesn't exist like we don't have a 55 so
let's say if we ask for something that
doesn't exist so non exists equals oops
equals count
fifty-five now in a normal dictionary
doing this would return an error like a
key error and but let's see what happens
when we try this so print
non exists run that and we return zero
instead as in there's zero instances of
that in this list so a little bit
different than a dictionary there as far
as what happens when you ask for a count
of a non-existent item next up though
just like any list or dictionary the
next thing you can do is redefine an
object so you can do something like
let's say we want count one so this is
referring to anything that equals like
it would be asking like how many
instances of one are there and in this
case I think we had what three so
normally this equals three but then we
can we can say nope it doesn't equal
three anymore it equals fifteen
so now what we can do is we can print
counts one and just make sure and then
also let's print just counts everything
like the entire dictionary and let's see
how it worked so not only did it indeed
work it changed it to 15 it also changed
it in our actual list itself and you'll
see how that impacts it later on as well
when we do a few more commands so let's
come down further I'm going to comment
these out again and not only can you you
redefine something to say 15 you could
in theory do kind of like a pseudo
delete and you can do something like
this counts 1 equals 0 now print counts
and let's run this list see what
happened now as you can see it prints
out the list and this time one is no
longer 15 it's now equal to 0 and it's
being included in the list but what if
you didn't want it in the list at all
well you can also delete it if you want
and so let me just comment that out and
now you could say like oops
del counts 1 and now we can save print
counts and run that and now you can see
there is no instance of a one right you
see some ones here but that's actually
how many of that number are there so
there is no key of one so that's how you
could remove it if you really wanted to
remove it or just reassign it if you
didn't want to remove it entirely so I'm
going to comment these two out again so
our counts of one is now equal to 15
again so it's the most popular item in
this list again now if you have a
counter and you've converted a list into
a counter or maybe you read a list into
memory and then you converted it to a
counter and you kind of tossed it out of
memory and you're like oh man now I need
it back into a list what would you do
well you can convert it to a list doing
the following so you could say x equals
list and then you could say counts dot
elements empty parameters it's a
function right and then now let's print
X run this and now you get a list of
these elements and now you'll notice too
that it doesn't it has 15 occurrences of
ones now the other thing you'll notice
is this is an ordered list by a number
of occurrences right so it doesn't
return to you the same order that you
know you first fed through but that's a
way to turn it into a list of elements
now the next thing that we can do is we
can count like instead of just taking
the return value because sometimes or
right most of times when you're counting
something you're trying to find maybe
the top 5 most popular items or the top
two or sometimes even the top one so how
can we do something like that well you
can say something like y equals counts
dot most underscore common and let's say
we just want the most common two so
print Y I'm going to comment out this
other print apps run it and we can we
get a return it's a list of a list right
so we've got the first one where it's
the most popular is a one with 15
occurrences so that's that and then
we're also return to two with the most
or with eight occurrences and second
most
and then you can obviously do like why
one if even though you called the most
common two you want just to know what
the first first one is and it returns
you know a single list and then finally
you could do a take it even further
oops let's actually get the just the
number so the most common and actually
y1 is the second element so let's get
the most common one here so this would
return the most common one which is
indeed a one so close out of this and
let me comment this out so that would be
a way to get the most common key now the
next thing that you can do is actually a
pretty interesting and it's a way where
you can add or subtract lists you cannot
multiply or divide lists sadly so now
let's make another list so we're going
to make another list literally and I'm
just going to put a bunch of random
stuff in this one again just like we did
with the other one
so you don't have to type this out
exactly like I did you can just make it
random so the next thing we're going to
do is we're going to say counts two
equals capital seat counter another list
done now the next thing that we want to
do is let's go ahead and just print
counts to make sure we got this four
correctly and so again we have this
counter and we see that two is now our
most popular but also one is the
second-most popular and so on closing
out of that obviously we can perform the
same operations that we've been doing
but let's do something new so now we're
going to say Z equals and what we're
going to do with this is we're going to
say it equals count plus counts two I'm
going to comment this one out so our
only return is Z then we're going to
print Z so let's see what it gives us
now so now as you can see it gives us a
combined answer right to our question
and again this gives us a counter and a
you know in dictionary like format so we
can do all of the same stuff that we've
done above to Z now subsequently we can
also change this to a subtraction and
then still print Z so let's run that and
now you can see we've got the list and
it's actually a much shorter list so
what happened was some of these
items subtracted so much to the point
where the result was zero or less than
zero
so it's taken out of the list because
the counter is meant to tally the amount
of instances so negative numbers are not
appreciated by counter so that's going
to conclude my tutorial for counter I
know that was a lot of stuff to throw at
you guys as far as the counter but it's
a lot of little basic functions of this
massive function but you'll find
yourself sometimes wanting to do
something like this like count the most
popular stuff and it's a little
difficult to do it all on your own but
the counter function really does it and
it comes with a lot of these other
little functions like the adding and
subtracting and the most common and all
this stuff that actually is made a very
intuitive on the part of whoever made
that function so very useful and that's
going to include this tutorial hopefully
you guys found it useful as always
thanks for watching thanks for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time